did it for about six years
six months oh yeah it was burr yeah man
that's a show man that is that is a show
that is work
that's work
eight shows a week
eight shows a week how much weight you
lose for that show dude i lost weight
every damn day
because
i doing that kind of work he's like
sammy davis and listen to me sam days
has been a little shaky boom go
that's the secret man you gotta turn it
on
mickey jackman
[Music]
i'm mike tyson this is the mic typing
show and this is my partner heavy hoodoo
there we go guys we have a special guest
today wayne brady the actor the singer
the comedian the gamer
i mean what don't you do i'm not gonna
tell you
because i like to keep it keeps a
mystery as long as folks think that you
can do everything that you keep on
working that's what this is about you
keep working amen yeah man i'm so
excited to be here champ thank you
thanks man nice to meet you bro yeah
likewise likewise so man tell us a
little bit about your story about your
upbringing man because obviously you
become successful out of you know
you know from night to night like you
know there was a process through your
life you talked a little bit about your
yeah
oh yeah well in a nutshell i'm from uh
orlando florida i was born in columbus
georgia at three months i guess uh i was
moved because i don't remember it of
course to orlando i was raised by my
grandmother because my dad was in the
army uh you know in nam and then in
germany and just traveling so he wanted
me to have a a stable upbringing my
folks are from the u.s virgin islands
saint thomas saint gessen croy so my
grandmother you're first generation
american well to be from the virgin
islands it's still to be an american
because it's a territory okay okay so
it's like it's like puerto rico
yeah yeah yeah i've never been there
mike oh dude really yeah it's absolutely
gorgeous absolutely gorgeous so i was
yeah so so in a way you know i'm
definitely first generation here um
being being brought up in in
and so my childhood raised in a
neighborhood
called tangelo park no one ever tells
you
that the black sex [ __ ] yeah yeah
because when folks think of orlando you
think of disney right so you think of
disney you know how the [ __ ] we have
probably out here that we uh we ran out
oh nothing but some black [ __ ]
out there all over the place downtown
[ __ ] yes sir
because you don't think that
you say what though yeah
folks think it looks like you know
something right well it's the south
folks forget because of disney they
don't think of it being the south south
but it's the south and everything that
comes along with that i was raised
hearing every kind of [ __ ] being
thrown and thrown at me and blah blah
blah blah blah that's so much power you
don't even know until it's
projected on you would you like to see
your kids mike someday like go back to
brownsville for a little bit of time
just to kind of did you ever think of
doing some things like that but i'm just
saying you as a follower i have my
mentor he has kids and he's he's almost
sometimes he's like man i got to take my
kids to mexico they need a witness like
real poverty in order for him to
understand kind of dick how do they
witness that with him
did they witness it by themselves
before they could um engage with the
dangers you engage with which they have
no experience to do which is what you
work
as as a parent to eliminate you want to
give your kids a better life than you
ever had so
i don't want my i don't want my kids
meeting guys like
me as a child that's what you've worked
for
is people have said to set that up how
was how was it mike for you when you're
uh when you were a kid man when you were
12 13 yeah yeah
it was hard it's never hard you know
what you nothing was giving you what i'm
saying when you're on the streets mike
you know how you know what i mean like
that's my life yeah that's just being on
the streets at 10 years old
four in the morning that's just my life
me and my friends get high
it's my life don't know nothing else
besides becoming
who i am now what who just got mike
tyson
and all those experiences add up to you
so oh no that makes me who i am
but you can't put that on the kids
because it's it it it's interesting to
hear yeah do you get where i'm coming
from though oh yeah and i've had that
thought too but if i took my daughter
back to my neighborhood which which
she's visited because my grandmother and
my aunt still live in the same place and
i've tried to get them to live with me
for years and years but i also don't
want to make my child a tourist because
i think i think there's a little bit of
um because then it would be unorganic
right like it was just
unorganic but it's false yeah and then
it's also like see where i'm from you
don't want to i don't like that i'm
proud of where i'm from but i but that's
not where she has grown up so i don't
want her to experience that yeah so
so the same not be lucky as we are yeah
and get out she may she may not be that
lucky yeah yeah like kids have their own
goals right now and that's why you work
so hard hard as a parent to set up a
different paradigm now you did bring up
man because my girl she was raised by
her
i mean how was it being raised by your
by your grandmother man like you know i
mean the old school principal you know
you know that curiosity i love you
afraid to beat your ass boom
and now now you know that you know
that's the hot debate among parenting
and even in the uh the school circles
about
about corporal punishment and there
there is definitely an old school and
especially in the i think in the black
and latin communities of where you know
you step out of line mom and dad smack
you and i can say that for me
it worked to a degree my my grandmother
didn't have to beat my ass more than
just a couple times in my life for me to
shake some of the friends that i was
with
and i kind of stayed on a path getting
into grandparents getting in the beat
and that ass that's just it's just a
twist
you're not gonna keep but you're gonna
feel like you're dying yeah that's just
a specialty belts switches the extension
cords they might even tell you to go get
your [ __ ] depending on who your
grandmother did yes and this is foreign
to some kids
watching this this is foreign to them
they know not to bring those little
switch they know nothing they know they
a monster turn a tamer you bring a
little switch you dead [ __ ] because you
thought that if i get well if i get the
skinny thing then it won't that will cut
your ass uh
so i learned quick yeah i don't know
yeah i'll just stay out of trouble you
know all that comes from
slavery beating your ass for the master
don't have to
save you that depression or mission
whatever it was no you're talking about
like you discipline and hitting your
kids you talk about talking about like
the the you know the stick and you know
when when you're beating them let's
teach them stay in line for the big man
that's what it's all about most of our
characteristics comes from that
a slave ancestors
there there's definitely a generational
trauma
that plays out all the time even with
corporal punishment so in talking about
you know being raised old school
i didn't necessarily mind it because i
think it
it worked for whatever reason but i do
think that especially in the black
community
just turning to when i'm a whoop your
ass
that
in some households is a substitute for
let me listen to you first see what's
going on with you and let me parent you
hands-on yeah versus i'm gonna parent
you and beat you the beating doesn't
necessarily help
that's what i think it's just my opinion
doesn't it
it's like capital punishment we've seen
everybody you know i know if i do this
they're going to kill me the
government's going to kill but still it
doesn't stop people from killing people
mm-hmm i'm serious and it depends on
what state you're in
if i shoot you and they're gonna hang me
up if i kill him or her they're gonna um
fight and swap me or something crazy
electrocute me
and it still doesn't prevent people from
murders murder rate is even higher
because the end result isn't the thing
and that's the thing with corporal
punishment you do understand that right
yeah it's even higher the murder rate is
even higher since the electricity and
all that stuff came back into existence
instead of looking at the end goal of if
you do this crime
i'm going to kill you or i'm going to
hang you i'm going to do this
let's go to where the root of the
problems are why are these people
committing crimes what can you do to
alleviate all of that
and that's not where the money's being
spent it's being spent on incarceration
and the end result instead of the
programs that would help people not
commit the crimes you know how you stop
crying like you stop hating on it you're
not gonna have to stop pain
if you can't stop pain
you can't stop all that all this is
coming from pain well there's an empathy
piece too because you have to understand
that people are going through pain and i
think this is the conversation that's
happening now
because of the pandemic and because of
the black lives matter movement and
everything that's happening
there's a lot of people screaming out in
pain exactly and that's the thing is how
do we deal that pain and that's the part
i think that pisses me off when i listen
to people especially even people that
call themselves allies they don't want
to have or listen to certain race
conversations because well i don't want
to hear that i didn't do it i wasn't a
slave owner i like black people i mean
for don't talk over us
just listen to what's being said if you
show some empathy and go oh you know i i
hear that
kindness and compassion
they're more powerful but on the flip
side mike you know what i'm thinking is
we also need to have
kindness and compassion for each other
and empathy for each other because it
goes both ways yeah it goes both way
what separated you wayne obviously did
you know you were special since you were
a kid you think you think you were born
with this gift or when did you discover
it that's a tricky question because you
you could end up sounding mad arrogant
if you're like well i knew i was special
each kid should feel that they have
something but i
but in my mind i knew that
i was a little different than a lot of
the kids around me because of my
interests you know what i mean that you
yeah like you know when you got some
something that not anybody has i possess
something different than myself it could
have been my ego but it's not so it was
i know there's something good that
happened to me mm-hmm yeah there's that
spark that if you know that you've got
some something it doesn't mean that you
think you're special and better than
somebody else it's just that i know that
i've got this thing and it's up to you
what you decide to do with it and i knew
i had something from the time that i was
uh you know i
my grandmother being the overprotective
grandma that she was she kept me in the
house a lot which
i was made fun of by a lot of the other
kids in the neighborhood because hey i
had a really strong accent because i was
raised by my grandmother and grandfather
and they spoke with a very strong island
accent and so so between the accent and
what they thought of my parents and i
was the kid that wasn't always there i
have a grandmother but from legend she
was just like a man who ran the house
your husband just made some money
no mike you said you were raised by your
grandmother no i said
i've never been raised but um grandma's
legendary she didn't take little [ __ ] so
so she ruined the roost yes yeah
yeah man hood grandma's our special
breed
and and keep the family together
and this is like the 20s we talked about
in brooklyn the 30s hmm it's almost like
they have they have that mentality that
just cut the [ __ ] out of like grandma's
like no this is this is what it is
listen my daughter's just me and my wife
just be talking back you better do this
hey stop stop when she went over
i'ma beat your black ass now i'm not
gonna say it again boom she goes right
away
no
yeah
get your black ass over here now
she's never heard that stuff before she
heard that coming from grandma yeah yeah
that's traumatizing that'll make me to
she heard that
she needs to have that 50 she don't have
it for me and my mother see um this is
interesting my girls i love them because
the whole way die killer but i don't
understand them you know i just don't
understand them
they what does they want they want it
all then they don't i i just don't even
try so did you do you feel like as a
father mike do you feel like them
experiencing other
other emotions because obviously that's
like a shocker you know what i'm saying
do you think do you do you you're it
seems like you're you're good with that
it's like you want to give that to your
kids
wow i used to want them to be hanging
out with guys like me when i was a kid i
want them to go a totally different
route which
some of them have and then some of them
got it in them they're not going to do
that they're not going to do what i want
them to do how old are your kids
they're adults they graduate out of
college and everything wow
so you've got grown folks
so they're already making their own
decisions right now absolutely so my
daughter's getting mad she's like 32
she's getting married congratulations
thanks and it's next year right but
after i started giving her money already
before the [ __ ] um
save up for us we'll just do it now for
next year and be prepared everything be
here
we'll pay for it now but um
i gotta remember it's not my [ __ ]
wedding you know
i agree with my way hey you take this
take the 25 000 you spend this on the
dress i'll pay for the other shoes and
everything
and the reality is she doesn't have an
ego like me she's not gonna spend 25 000
on a [ __ ] wedding
she's gonna probably spend 500 weddings
just to keep the rest in the [ __ ]
banks account and then wait for daddy to
spend money and pay for that
did you uh did you get some expensive
suits mike or something like no but it's
just that no this is telling me this
everybody doesn't have my out of whack
ego
everybody doesn't want to show off and
[ __ ] on people and balls and all that
people just want a simple life
and i sometimes i try to afford i try to
force my life for my kids and these guys
are not about that stuff
but i want my kids and people start
coming around asking for
um autographs and pictures that turns
them off yeah they want to spend time
with their fathers and they see that
protect this out
my ego they see that i spend a lot of
time with the people kissing my ass yeah
i said to them and they really love me
and they're sincere yeah that's
unconditional yeah my ego [ __ ] with me
sometimes and say i already got that
get this yeah
do you feel mike a little bit because
you're a public figure too man oh yeah
you know obviously you're recognized
people know you you're pulled
in listening to you talk yesterday i did
an instagram live with this cat
where where he hit me with a quote that
that that hit me so hard
that
i thought oh [ __ ] this is what i've been
doing my daughter's entire life
it's like
when
the world gets the best of you
gets the person who is bright and shiny
and you sign autographs and you'll do
things
and that energy that you've given to the
world because it goes along with the
profession
your family gets the rest of you
and that that brought me nearly to tears
because
we had a whole conversation about you
know
ego and toxic masculinity and what does
that mean right now and being a father
and your family right yeah yeah my
family yeah that too so that's deep so
being a public figure whoever you are
it's a double-edged sword the thing that
makes you you that people are drawn to
you're banking on the fact that people
know who you are that makes you valuable
in the workspace
if you give all of that by the time that
you get home you're like look i just
want to can i not just
look i don't wanna talk i don't wanna
run around i don't wanna do x y and z
because i'm bright and shiny all the
damn time
that's deep when your kids are like hey
but i would like some some of that or or
your partner
i would like the man that i love to be
bright and shiny for me so why do i just
get the cranky ass dude
[Laughter]
my birthday had passed by what 40
and when i had to get something but you
know it was just like twisting their
[ __ ] arms and said happy birthday
daddy we love you i was like oh [ __ ]
on my birthday i found the phone my kids
don't even like me what the [ __ ] i'm
thinking i'm a good guy i said the money
looking out from co
[ __ ] that helps them you know
and they were right i am so stupid
and god complex sometimes because i have
a low self-esteem from my childhood
yeah you know so i replaced that with
indestructible and all that [ __ ]
that sam god
and
my kids think that's really me
they think i really look at myself and
that's my ethos or whatever it is my
whole barometer of the person but they
don't know this is um
this is paying for your school
have you shared that with them i don't
think they understand the concept of me
being i ain't mike tyson and me being
dad
they understand maybe i bring mike to
the house of sometimes
do you feel like you have to shift your
role a little bit mike from uh for more
of of mike tyson to to dad
yeah with certain children yes you got
seven kids right now yeah certain
certain children
everybody all of them are different a
different person out of these different
egos
totally different
but they have to understand that no one
gave this to me
i'll pay for your rooms and your phone
but nobody pays for my good time
yeah you know i don't mind doing that
either i like doing that but i want to
know what it's like
to break their back a little i don't
want to be able to give it under the
slightest struggle yeah and that's what
happens when you know you take care of
men and women all their lives
so they have to do something for
themselves slightly struggling to give
it yeah it's like you want to you feel
like you want to give more of that
teaching to your kids yeah maybe that's
not for them because you hadn't
mentioned the conversation that yeah her
grandmother had with your daughter and
then you had just mentioned what you
mentioned you know what i'm saying it
seems like you want to give them
experience which there's no money that
could that could that could pay for a
hundred percent muhammad tell a person
who's educated basically
one of some of the best colleges in the
world that this is where you come from
and this is who your father is
and they're looking at me and they don't
understand a word that i'm saying don't
get it yet they'll never get it because
they have to be in there and living that
but did you have those conversations
with them
early on so that they
wouldn't know who you are because i had
it from when little kid i'm still doing
it to this day
that's a
that's a man
that's that's such a specific
type of relationship and you would have
had to have been
in the shoes of someone who comes from
from a certain background who comes from
the hood and and then you've done well
for yourself and you've had kids that
conversation is so different it ties
back into what we started talk talking
about in the beginning which you know
taking your kid back and showing them
this what not that'll never be their
experience but if you can impress upon
them like i really tried hard
from the time that my daughter was able
to understand to to tell her said hey
you have a very
privileged life and i'm glad for that
because this is where i'm from but i
also want you to understand that it's
privileged and i want you to understand
me so i've tried to have that talk with
her and there are times when you know
what i've felt
that
she's been ungrateful and i've had to
think to think about that because i
would get mad about that but it's not
that she's being ungrateful she just
doesn't have anything to
to right it's right it's a concept she
has nothing to scale it against
so the best that we can do i feel
sometimes is just to
be honest with them and then at a
certain point you have to set them up
for success by going hey you got to do
this on your own
easier said than done because you never
want them to
go but i just i just feel like it's a
process you know like anything you know
it's a process mike and i think you know
i i feel for you mike because god you're
mike tyson you know i mean like the
probably though you're probably mike one
of the top three
most recognizes face in the world
absolutely i mean can you think of
anybody you know it's it's hey listen
i accidentally when i was a kid
and my mentor said be careful what you
asked for
wayne went from uh from obviously from
studying acting since the beginning to
arrive in hollywood man i want to know
your hollywood struggle stories but i'm
back because you came here in 96 right
was 96 it was yeah something like that 9
95 96.
before i got here i i'd already been
acting for
i mean since i was 16 and so i got here
when i was like 22 20 23
and i didn't know what to expect
you you get off the plane
just like anybody else thinking this is
the land of
of opportunity i can come i think you
can i break i was born i think that's
the opportunity you could be whatever
the [ __ ] you want
listen you know what really you don't
understand that what you're hanging out
with on the school schwarzenegger's
chilling out yeah this is a foreign guy
he came he couldn't speak the language
of another i think that was one of the
coolest experiences i've ever had man
yeah that's the american dream
personified yeah you hear what you said
what he did
became a brute and everybody loved him
they learned the language then he
learned all of the infrastructure about
this country
and then he became a governor
yeah this is definitely a place of
opportunity this in new york you know so
when i got here i i struggled but i'm
going to say that i was fortunate
because going back to i always knew that
i was going to do something didn't know
what it was and all all i ever asked god
for i said look i i just want to work
so i never thought that i'd be on tv or
folks would know my name or i get to do
all the cool [ __ ] that i've done i said
i just want to work so when i got here i
hustled i worked um
luckily most of my jobs were in
entertainment i worked at universal
studios
doing theme park shows i was in the
beetlejuice rock and roll show and i was
uh in a stunt show there and i was a
doo-wop singer um you remind me so much
as sammy davis doing yeah well sammy was
one of my idols you know sammy and ben
ben vereen
come on man
shout out to ben ben is like mike
brooklyn my godfather man i he uh he and
i talk all the time i call and pops and
he calls me son i feel like i'm in a
direct spiritual
descendant of him and those cats like
sammy that opened the door and the thing
that i from the time i was a kid and
reading these books about sammy was like
you have to make yourself the most
valuable person in the room so learn as
much as you can do as much as you can
you know sammy i'm not saying mr sonata
says
the best um the best revenge is success
absolutely absolutely uh um across the
board
because it's the way that you can
no matter what someone thinks of you
regardless of race or your economic
background or whatnot as long as you can
bring something to the table that they
can't
that's an amazing power i guess yeah
family was so bad sam was a bad bad man
i'm i'm sad
i never got a chance to meet him but i
met his wife so bad he was fly he was
flying
man you got to hang out with sammy i had
the chance to meet him and i
had to talk to him and see that he was
like us
man that's something that i wish i would
have gotten a chance to meet him i met
his uh wife altavis before she passed
and she came to see me at the hollywood
bowl and i did a night one night which
was me doing sammy davis junior songs
and she came up to me afterwards and she
gave me stuff of his that i still have
she gave me some books and pictures that
he signed and she said sammy would have
loved to have met you and that was one
of the greatest compliments anyone could
have paid it paid me my life
ever uh
so i definitely hustled when i got out
here i delivered big um i had had a job
for one day
that i was a messenger for one day when
i first got here and that's back in the
day of thomas guides
um when you had to use a thomas guide
instead of gps to figure out where you
were and i did know this damn city and i
drove around for six hours trying to
deliver
i believe there were architectural plans
because they were in that tube yeah at a
certain point
i was like this this is six hours in i
can't find my way i'm lost i'm by the
airport i don't know where i am
screw it so somebody didn't get to build
a house
because
i tossed that tube and i was like i'm
out
um and i work kids parties i sang at
supper clubs they got that
stuff that you're telling us that then
still don't tell us who you are oh but
that's a big piece of who i am check
this out where did you get that
that thought that i'm somebody i i got
it because i heard that i wasn't
somebody
yeah that's the st that i understand
that too that's the thing that that if
you have enough people and i don't want
to take up the whole the whole show
talking about it about
this unlimited time here but but in a
nutshell you know like i was explaining
earlier about growing up in the
neighborhood i grew up
it's amazing to feel othered as an other
and what i mean about that is it's grown
up in my hood
i always felt different and i was made
fun of or i was told that i wasn't black
enough or i was told my family was this
i was told that or like uh you know it's
weird when another black person says to
you like i wrote this whole
thing that's on spotify right now this
thing called uh the angriest black man
in america
or something something where this girl
in my front yard in front of all these
kids said to me this light skin girl she
as we were all playing she said wayne
brady
use a real ugly [ __ ] and wrapped
her mouth around [ __ ]
and i was a
uh
why
because you black
now
you're black so what do you mean i'm bl
i know i'm black why would that be a
so when she said that word to me
being i don't know i was like 10 or
something
the head games the way that i can [ __ ]
with you
i'm in a neighborhood full of black
people but you just told me
that i'm ugly because i'm black
but you also say that i'm not black
enough because of whatever your reasons
are
so
that does a job on you
and we no no
imagine the job it did
that's the
yes and that's the piece that it's that
trauma piece and whatnot because she had
to get that from some place i heard
people hurt people brother
hurt people hurt people and now that's
why you have to have
empathy for each other
because
and that's when i realized that
i
needed to
even at that age i knew that i was going
to take whatever talent i had and nobody
knew that i could sing dance act or do
anything because i've like was in my
little room watching tv and reading
books and doing
audio plays and we're working on voices
and imagining things nobody knew i could
do anything until
i was like 15 or 16. they're like oh
[ __ ] wayne can sing when you did because
i was training i was in hiding i said
i'm going to train by myself i'm going
to study sammy and these greats and
and i'm going to come out swinging
because that's going to be my way out
so that made me so each time that
somebody had some [ __ ] to say to me
about well i wasn't this or i wasn't
that i wasn't i was going to take that
and i was going to use success you're
right success is the best revenge i i
was going to use that to take myself out
of that situation but the bad part about
that is you begin to weaponize it so so
in instead of me saying that i want it
to be
we look at success as a weapon yeah and
it shouldn't be yeah it could be afraid
yeah it should be joyful we don't ever
want to be hurt again so we use it as a
weapon yes sir
yeah yeah i think it's the most powerful
non-existent element in the world
doesn't even exist but it's powerful
because it drives you or it stops you
from being driven
but if it got you driven
yes
yeah but you don't also think it was a
bit of you had this god-given ability
the reason why i said god-given is
because improv that stuff is not easy
man you ever tried playing charades yeah
if it was god-given he wouldn't have to
train through it
you know god gives you the
ability
but you know if you don't train yeah
right know yeah god gives you the
gives you the thought right right it's
like an iq yeah when when folks are like
well i've got an iq of such and such
that's dope you you can have an
incredibly high iq but don't get it
twisted your iq is not how smart you are
your your iq is your capacity so you can
have a high iq but if you don't use it
or train that's right you're right but
it is a gift what i'm saying is you
recognize that gift that you absolutely
it was and you worked on it but
because you're going from singing
to dancing
can we can we roll up one of uh no nevi
um
me and wayne brady do it every little
step that's one of the best moments in
my life
that's one of the best moments in my
life
doing this you don't know
the joy in my heart
when we called and we asked mike tyson
hey mike let's have oh oh because it was
after i saw the documentary and and we
reached out and you know i tell tell you
every time i see you i'm so proud of the
work that you do and the struggle and
the place where you've come from and the
honesty that you have have on yourself
growth and the person that you've made
yourself and so that was enough for me
to be able to go out to dinner and tell
mike that and then i pitched in this
stupid idea i'm like hey
let's do something funny together and he
said yes and that turned into us doing
every little step you take
we got this here it's so dumb and
awesome yeah so this this is how long
ago was this oh man i don't even know
what had my baby girl 2009 or 10th
yeah yeah i want to say 10.
how old is she now she's 12. then then
yes about 12 13 years ago
and and i've also got to say that
we're actually dancing like we're really
doing bobby brown's moves
what i was so impressed with about mike
and not to embarrass you being being
being here is first off mike didn't have
to do do the video
mike wanted to do the video his ego oh
you know you were talking about your ego
you you had no ego
he came in and learned the choreography
no but that's what's dope is your ego
said oh i'm going to do it and you're
supposed to somebody else would be like
no i don't want to look stupid i don't
want to look no no this is my youtube
that song is my youth killed it just
like big monkey died that's why that's
how you stay god bless bismarck
she's doing a lot of good stuff robin is
killing it right now she has the black
lady sketcher on hbo
he's young he was son man and
and then to have bob come out and do it
man that was so dope i
see it so this is an example of i feel
that certain things can't be funny
unless you can do it he learned the
choreography man
oh damn
[Laughter]
and then bobby brown showed up which was
so dope yeah that's so great
hey go mike hey
he had one rehearsal
i love this video i love this video so
much
see that's an example to me of when
someone
learns the lesson of you take yourself
seriously of course but you don't take
yourself so seriously that you're not
willing to be open to something new
listen you gotta be able to um to make a
fool of yourself and not taking some
serious
yeah
that's a big part of success right now
everybody thinks i'm mean
i'm a [ __ ]
you you can't be me you can't be afraid
to be and get embarrassed or to fail
right mike no how can you get
embarrassed but we're gonna die and go
somewhere how are you gonna embarrass me
yeah he's no better than me this is what
it is that's our problem now all the
things that we're
respecting we wouldn't do what this guy
this girl did and everything we're just
animals being taught to be human beings
we're not human beings but animals
taught to be human beings and some dig
this though
just like people
some learn faster than others
you know so the ones that don't get it
right away we have to do something to
those guys maybe put them in an
institution or something or keep them on
parole or some kind of way we have to
control them it's called eliminating all
brutes
much
would you get this from mike huh did you
did you uh study somebody on like what
is it yeah and my fact that is a
documentary eliminating all brutes
and it's just like when i read the
prince when i was a kid it's just how we
are
we look we're born to worship something
we have to worship something more than
us
some of us slip
through the hole and thank their god and
make these force
i don't know temples or
worships of god or whatever in all
religions
you know everybody look at it from a
dollar perspective not everybody
and that's just how the world goes
what's the name of the documentary again
eliminate all fruits
it's like when the mayflower came in
they saw the name of america they
started eliminate them for their land
and stuff
that's it
but
but is what you're talking about though
because now when i just read that i went
oh that's right i've heard of it i
understand the principle that you're
talking about but you know that
principle was also used
talking about the um
the mayflower that that principle was
used by white supremist so like that's a
unifying theory of white supremacy in
term in terms of we've got to eliminate
the brutes what they perceived as brutes
but but i think what you're talking
about is in life and nature the people
that exist outside of we all sign a
contract each day we walk outside we
sign a contract that i won't take a
hammer and smack this dude upside the
head or run this guy over with him
the unwritten law but those but there
are some people that they don't want to
to be governed by that unwritten law
those people have to be dealt with
because they make things worse for
the rest of us because of fear
but then how do you deal with those
people going back to what we were saying
earlier in terms of of um of corporal
punishment and the death sentence if
there are people that refuse to exist
within the parameters what do you do
with that person
no we do
rehabilitate him okay from a savage into
a
gentleman
or a lady
that's more powerful than killing though
that is powerful
but do you think there are people who
refuse for for whatever reason
they refuse to it's like you are you
mike just walked in and he's and he's
gonna try to to rehabilitate me and give
me the things that i need i don't want
it no i'm not gonna do that
i'm not going to do that
i don't know who's going to do that
but that is um
that's the way that we defeat our
enemies
we don't kill them
we um
we changed them that's great that's
positive
and that's true
i think that's the ideal i would like to
see that become more than just an ideal
because you're right it's more powerful
to convert and change than it is to
throw away the scar to destroy
you see malcolm x
a lot of people
a lot of people do that
um it's changed their life they want a
better life and the reason that we have
gangsters
in chicago killing themselves they don't
have hope for a better life
that's true
but i think the question still comes
back and it's such a rhetorical question
because what the answer is
not just in chicago but wherever that
type of violence exists
in those neighborhoods what do we do how
how do we get changed their way of
thinking
um this is a better part of life
and you don't have to do this it's love
loving someone
knowing someone loves you
even forgetting having a job
your standalone is powerful enough
to exist
because it's part of that trauma
absolutely cats are cats are operating
from a place of deep trauma even
the people who we think
got it all
they are too
i talk about this a lot you know i've
been outspoken about uh
mental health especially mental health
in the black community and and how you
know
it's at least growing up if you would
even mention a psychiatrist or therapy
that's not for us
i've been very vocal about mental health
and and honest about how i feel that i'm
driven by that therapy and feeling angry
which is at odds with the image that
some people have oh wayne is this safe
dude
he's like but you don't know me you
don't know the [ __ ] that i walk around
with daily
and you we don't know the [ __ ] that we
each walk around with daily yeah you
ever you ever you ever mess around with
the psychedelics or anything like that
you ever hear mike talk about the toad
yeah yeah which i've got to admit we
were even pre pre-show i was talking
with some of your producers about about
um you know mushrooms and stuff
i i'm on mushrooms right now yeah
which is
so as someone that's never done that how
does it open you because i've because
i've heard that it can be used to treat
treat uh mental illness and to treat
anxiety listen let me just
i don't even know how to um articulate
it so i'ma say i'm expressing like that
when you take the toad
you have to prepare not to be yourself
anymore you know you're gonna change
all right that's all i can tell you
if you like who you are right now and
stuff
don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ] it's gonna
make you better but that's the fear part
you gotta go beautiful this is gonna
make you better listen you know what i'm
not in the body it'll take you it might
correct me if i'm wrong it'll take you
in a life roller coaster listen
everything that's kind of happening
first time i did the totally lost 110
pounds man the same [ __ ] after that
for somebody
wait so you mean so you mean the the
the one time that you did it no the
second time okay the second time you did
it yeah but but how long does it last it
lasts like um 20 minutes
that's it
in 20 minutes you want to get like 2 000
years of experience in your favor
see that's some quantum [ __ ]
yes
that's what i said articulate yes he
gets a compression of time listen you
can't articulate it you're going to see
it you're going to see your
great-great-grandmother you go listen
you're seeing the first you
you know there's gonna be chinese men
the first male you the first guy that
when this dick comes out your bloodline
the first one you're gonna meet that
person
you know why i can't do it and maybe
this is you know we're talking talk
about fear
i was raised
because i saw so many cats that i grew
up with nah whether it was crack
especially crack crack at that point
crack or whatever
it was drilled into me and i joke about
this on stage it's like there are so
many things i've wanted to try but in my
mom's head of that when you go and die
so you don't smoke drugs you're going to
die so i hear in my head but i hear
about mushrooms and i hear about these
experiences and i want to
um
mushroom is not even a tenth of a
percent what this is
so when you talk about the toe you mean
the literal toad the yeah so what so
it's the sonora tote so it's also known
as the bullfrog so what they do is uh
especially the sonoran toad that's up in
like northern mexico arizona
months of the year you could i've never
seen that but it stays underground 10
months out of the year
yeah so when it comes out so you have
two months to catch it and then extract
the venom from it and then you smoke the
venom but it really like
he doesn't mike doesn't see this stuff
as a drug like to us it's like it's over
50 times probably
never having the same [ __ ] experience
you're always scared see i don't get
scared anymore because i always want to
look at it so i'm getting ready to go
die cuz you feel like you die but i look
at it i'm getting ready to go reborn get
reborn yeah and do you remember
the trips that you have like like like
the things that you sometimes you don't
but then you see some [ __ ] that like
whoa you can't you might hey it's over i
don't want to do this no
but you're but you you got to go for the
ride you're on the ride not going to
stop that that's what i'm afraid of
because i don't want to give up control
no listen you'll find out how powerful
you are once you get that up hmm yeah
listen
people think if it's a little bit that
people think you're uppity [ __ ] once
you get this you look at people
different you look at yourself different
and your whole desire your whole [ __ ]
um it's like a romney is being
successful it won't let you make an ass
out of yourself maybe sexual or
something but as far as doing some
stupid [ __ ] going with the wrong people
hanging out with the wrong people you
don't do that no more
you've got me contemplating listening
what it is is you know it's a little
different from everybody what it is it's
a it's kind of a psychology for you
like it shows you compassion bro it
shows you what really matters in life i
did it with mike about a year ago and i
was just like you know my trip was
different you know
my trip was different my own was like
man that brought me back to
when i was a baby like how my mom was
raised like it gives you it just gives
you the whole
answers
wow it'll be different for everybody man
but it's something that you got to be
ready for
and
you have to allow it to take anything
if i would ever saw somebody do it
before i did i wouldn't do it
yeah once your ego died you don't know
what you y'all know your faith you know
yo
and plus
under um the toad
it's gonna feel like all your secrets
that if they knew they wouldn't be my
friend the feeling of it being
exposed um
imagine that shoes they have
if i let them know this they don't look
at me different
it won't explode but the feeling that
you have that everyone knows it gives
you your weakest and your strongest
moments and at the end of the game it's
like to your god would it be like this
to mike it's almost like it strips you
naked and it teaches you like naked like
you know what i'm saying like
like you're exposed but it's so
beautiful matt cause you're saying like
oh my god i did this this and that it's
like
then you go back and look at the people
that that probably hurt you you're like
this this and that like you know what
i'm saying it's a trip it's it's you
reach a level of emotion whereas i hate
and love and everything in between how
beautiful everything is and all the time
in 20 minutes all of it oh this is all
this is 20. we find out the beauty of
death as well
in what way because um how could death
not be beautiful if life is beautiful
what did you exist for
you think god made life beautiful that
he's going to make
death not as equally beautiful this is
what um
buddha
existence was because he didn't
understand people
applying self-suffering
um suffering that he said some
that's not me for us humans are not
supposed to suffer
you know god didn't make anything here
for us to suffer but we put self-stuff
on it we want to i don't know we're
sociopaths
we're um that's and that's another word
what's that word when you're like
masochistic
most of us are like massacres we like to
feel pain we want to take the poison and
wait for you to die
you know that's just some mentalities
that we have out here
some people just in love
and there's so much love they want to
have a suicide pact with
i don't love you that much hey hey
no
it's not that you don't love that much
it's just that your understanding of
love
is limited at that level well it's
skewed yeah yeah at that level but it
just keeps going he's just even myself a
certain level hey [ __ ] chill and it
keeps going for people who has different
thoughts and passions about love so if
you're able to
use use the toad or use mushrooms that's
something that i've definitely thought
about now especially when it comes to
fun ice cream
mental health that's fun mushrooms all
that stuff is fun
and remember too when mike talks about
the toe bro it's not like you don't
become an addict through it like you
really don't know no no it's not like
yeah i'm missing that i like doing it
every day or whatever but even
you can even ask mike like even right
before he's getting ready to do it like
he fears it bro he's scared not no more
i used to be okay because i looked at it
as death and we were able to die today
because it was like a ego death
and i look at it being reborn now
i'm going to be reborn today so you use
the shrooms today not the toad because
if you use the toe then you wouldn't be
able to have this conversation no i'll
be on under some [ __ ] but after you
20 minutes later i'll be able to have
this conversation
wow you know sometimes i told you obama
you throw up you scream you cry it just
puts you in so many different emotions
what's the uh the they they think that
the
shaman used the awaska the oscars
were good with me that wasn't it with a
negative perspective of it so it didn't
work good with me but it stuck with me
for a long time like a month to stay
down my sister i need to try it again
under different circumstances of mental
allowance you know i gotta give myself
up and not be an arrogant guy
and that's what it's all about
um submission yes it's going to be a
great word it's going to make you submit
so you better you might as well go in
there already submit right so don't
fight i usually try to fight it
and then they showed me some bad
[ __ ] and i realized i'm not a
bad [ __ ] and that's admit oh
you think you're bad [ __ ] gonna show
you some bad [ __ ]
you'll be screaming oh no oh they're
gonna show you there's some scary people
out there that are you're scared of my
son
no no you have to depend on the
mentality you go in there right right
that's what it sounds like
yeah i go in there with the
perspective you know i'm nothing god is
everything glory goes to god so you can
win that [ __ ] with the
confidence it's just something it's
gonna matter it's gonna show you your
first time that you're nothing you just
said that off back shows you you know
it'll strip do you do it with a purpose
like before something you go oh yeah go
go i'm gonna use this yeah to get to
that next state like i'm getting ready
to have this exhibition and um oh i'm
totally on the toad
smoking
because it unlocks something in you
it's just uh explains to me who i really
am and i don't have to be a fake [ __ ]
you know it's even better it's just i'm
tuning into you it humbles you right
michael yeah it turns into you and you
work but listen i don't work but no
one's talking like and i used to say i'd
be football i was lying i didn't care
what people would say this is the first
time my life i don't give a [ __ ] they
don't express i don't even see their
[ __ ]
face
well you've lived long enough and done
enough to earn that just for yourself i
learned that after i been involved with
all my stuff because it's
difficult to learn when you're going
through all that stuff
you know
wow
sit on it sit on it wait no but it's
funny that we're having this talk
because we we didn't even talk before
the show but i've had this recommended
to me
as a means of
unlocking and and using it in a
therapeutic fashion and i was very much
on the fence because you know i've been
programmed to no i'm not going to do
some [ __ ] like that blah blah blah you
have to understand what you're told
right it's going to give you
understanding what it's like to be the
great one the universe you're going to
feel it
you know you're going to know you're
part of everything every person every
race every animal every tree every grass
every shadow
every dump waste
you with the beauty and
the so-called ugly but god made it all
so it can't be ugly it's just mm-hmm
it's just i like the understanding of it
you know
all right
all right well if i decide to i'm gonna
let you know
because
because i can talk to you about the the
experience oh that would be cool
when i first did i know i think let me
try it again
i know this thing i know what i use so i
didn't [ __ ] have money
mike gets a second dose bro let's try
that again
this is not right sun ain't right i need
to try this out this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
they did this on me they setting me up
so i had to take a look yeah
what type of environment did you do
within
um i'm by myself with the sherman
i'm on the floor i also allow my wife to
come in
and
i feel very safe with her so um i'm
feeling safe with the shaman too but
every experience
i experience that experience with my
wife so you gotta you got you have to be
with uh
with with loved ones or people that are
close to you because you don't want to
you don't want to ruin the experience
with somebody that people probably bring
[ __ ] with them do you agree mike there's
some dudes that are so corrupt they're
trying to do this toad that you just
can't be around as crazy as that sounds
dude no that's why i asked everything
what's the environment [ __ ] it's like a
ceremony
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ain't no ain't no hey [ __ ] do something
you know
this is this is uh divine
it sounds like that's what it is it
doesn't sound just like oh let's get
high it's it's a purposeful key yes you
can't even pay for it so you had to
always give donations
you can't take money for it so you have
to say donation
you can't sell it yeah bad old man can't
sell it can't exchange money for the
total
maybe for charity of the toad and he
passes forward but your intention is
giving this money it's just for
donations and not for buying this
because this can't be bought it's not
supposed to be bought but wayne sit on
that wait i just no i'm gonna sit on
that for real as a five-time emmy award
winner is that is that surreal to you
man absolutely it's a real team
i never think the money unless it's a
donation isn't it creator what uh this
is
donation send the slant the the sly word
to me take the money i don't know it's
just
it's just because you don't want the
karmic blow it's blowing it's possible
because we're supposed to be god made
this was on a [ __ ] toad you can't
sell this [ __ ] so
well well i'm not going to ask you i was
going to ask you because i was going to
ask you because a lot a lot of things
will will be stripped like even though
like even like the question that i asked
you like having the you know being a
five-time emmy award winner
that [ __ ] doesn't matter man like it's a
trick
nothing like nothing right mike yeah
like i don't walk around even thinking
about those things because i think that
that yeah like it's great when you've
achieved certain certain bench
benchmarks but at a certain point you
know in a certain age in a certain place
in your life it's about
yeah it's about your family you're
getting better too but it's still
getting [ __ ]
mm-hmm it's in you can't your family
can't stop it for me nothing god put it
in you awards getting [ __ ] i'm a
competitor of life
because you got to be be a competitor
right
right if you don't compete but you you
you knew that yeah you know that already
yeah man if you don't compete
where
where are you going to sit well there's
all these twigs the romans even the
ancient africans they always allowed the
kids to fight fight hard fight your
brother's heart punch him in the face
kick him fight hard because um they
didn't want you to give in on the
slightest struggle they want you to have
some kind of game in you some kind of
thoroughbred legend
because you have to life life itself is
a struggle and even listening to you
talk about toe guitar and everything
whatever the thing is that you use
as a tool
to help you
stay in the game and compete if it's
that to help your mental state so that
you could do all your [ __ ] listen this
is what listen to this listen
oh i can't even say that you can't tell
the toe what it's doing what you and me
with you know you just can't say i'm do
this if this is good enough the toe was
[ __ ] on you
the toe is god
that's what i'm trying to tell you this
is your closest
similar regard until you die
wow
you know you might see him but i can't
see him but i could feel
that's where you almost see him like you
feel the intensity of feeling the impact
that the toe gives you the feeling of
being an empath will blow your mind and
do you feel them each time your feelings
of divineness it humbles you
it just humbles you it doesn't even make
you think that you it gives you that
problem i'm not bad but it humbles you
to know that it's that kind of power out
there and you're really nobody and i
think i'm a bad [ __ ] but all
right y'all i'm nobody i miss a piece of
the puzzle
well anybody who thinks that they're bad
[ __ ] just like you were saying
it's it
no no you said god god given
you can have all that power to be the
baddest but it's not yours it didn't
come no from you right once you noticed
by god
you noticed by the devil too
he can't know about you another guy i
don't
right his job is to crush everything god
does so he got he he spotted this guy
well you know the saying right when
we're kids kids you know the devil is a
busy man oh man but listen he's really
not busy because
he's like the line he sends us the
minions out to cause [ __ ] he's he's not
he's chilling hanging out with god
talking some [ __ ] but he had this
opinion about doing chicago history
about doing [ __ ] and we're the best
guard with because if you're on your
grind then the demons are on their grind
too
absolutely it's not that easy man this
the
world i would look for the polarity um
if i don't have this bad [ __ ] the good
[ __ ] don't exist which i've never
thought about even when you talked about
death because i think i'm like like a
lot of folks i'll be honest i fear death
you you do everything in your
power to never you know we're all going
to see life life is something to fear
you don't know what shit's going to
happen you know death you know from your
perspective it's just death
dude he's he's fighting about it that's
true you know i never thought or thought
of it that way
just silence love this is coming at you
hey no because there you go
life is the ultimate improv show
it's the ultimate improv show and death
is great
yeah you know what i'm saying we die our
spirit's gonna go somewhere no but
that's it it's us at highest potential
wow
how do you hand listen
listen i know he says he'll say i don't
think myself but then in my brain my
brain tells me [ __ ] wow you're the
baddest [ __ ] that did this you
the baddest [ __ ] that did that
but it still says
he wasn't nice to those people huh
that's what the shooting soon put you in
that [ __ ] to make you so hard of hearing
god this doesn't hit you with this hey
remember you didn't treat that person
that good i don't know why it does it to
you
i don't know why it does it to me puts
me talking about how great i am i'm also
god listen listen i'm that person you
didn't treat too good that girl this
time remember that they this enough whoa
and i said hey that rusted to my wife
baby baby i'm sorry at this room to get
this [ __ ] with me baby it's [ __ ]
with me so i told you not to use the
damn shrooms
she'll assume to take you somewhere man
you make you think you're somebody
special okay
remember you did this maybe you did that
you didn't treat that person because it
shows you both both sides so maybe it's
got to set you up because then you
wouldn't get get the lesson i think like
the feeling has when you almost feel
like you're god and anybody else is here
just to entertain you yeah and then
start going through hey you wasn't a
good person to that person last time i
mean you did this to that person yeah i
used to run upstairs
talk to us a little bit about the
philanthropy man you have an academy uh
here in los angeles yeah i'm starting an
academy with uh the group called
freestyle love supreme lin lin-manuel
miranda who uh wrote uh hamilton and in
the heights yeah i've been i've been to
hamilton i went backstage i met all the
guys great show right
um i did date it for about six you said
six months oh yeah it was burr
yeah man that's a show man that is that
is a show
that is work
that's work
eight shows a week no that worked eight
shows a week but i was so for the worst
things man
i was so happy to do that [ __ ]
but lynn has a group called freestyle
love supreme which we're good which will
be how much weight just moves for that
show dude i lost weight every damn day
because you're running around on stages
because
i do that kind of work that's the best
shape i mean whenever i'm doing broadway
because because you have to train for
what folks don't realize is to be a
broadway performer you are an athlete
not not like to act in a show but if
you're doing a musical where you're
singing dancing acting and doing
character you you you have to keep your
body in tip-top shape right you have to
eat right yeah because i imagine like
you're speaking and you gotta act you
gotta move especially you like you gotta
hold it right you have to hold it
together you can't drink because you
lose your voice you can't stay out late
you kind of live this very
boxing yeah listen he's like sammy david
don't listen to me sam days has been a
little shaky boom go
that's the secret man turn it on
[Laughter]
you always got to have that thing thing
in you and so i'm trying to inspire
other kids that i feel were like me so
with freestyle love supreme i'm starting
my academy which is kind of like the
groundlings or second city here in los
angeles and one in new york where we'll
have outreach into all the neighborhoods
compton
englewood los angeles trying to bring
acting and improv and schools
so that we can teach them improvisation
is all based on the yes and thing right
so so it's yes and so you accept the
challenge that life gives you and you
yes to that
people
by doing that that's what i want to i
want to create
that's what i want because i wish i
would have had people to guide me like
that so i'm starting that academy it'll
be open by the first part of next year
that's so smart
and and then so we'll have a theater
company as well we're going to open up a
theater here and that's yeah that's the
way to do it's like magic johnson look
at what magic
johnson's been able to do with his
platform for basketball
they're not making any more land so you
have to buy as much as you could
possibly can
especially in los angeles if you want to
make money on this earth or something
specific
you know
you have to make an investment and
you're right because they're not
creating any more of it so it's like can
you take this property jackson home
wyoming florida
this is where we get you have to get
property at and this is where people go
um what's those what's the scheme place
ass aspect that's where you get these um
homes where people can go they rent from
you they're like airbnbs and things like
that yeah my wife knows they really fly
great-looking houses my wife put it
together she is just amazing in that
stuff
i guess all women just wait for the
opportunity so they can show themselves
and show what they're capable of doing
because she's really showed me a lot of
stuff that since i've known her since
she was 19 so i seen the change in her
yeah well she handles your your business
man and and so
she she she's awesome she really is cool
i agree with you so so awesome
when i i look at your schedule and i'm
i'm like dude
you're a busy man
man if you stay he's not busy enough
tell me you're not busy you can always
be busier right yes you can always be
busier but i've got a lot of stuff in
fact like right right now you know as
soon as we offend it finish this i gotta
bounce right now because i'm because
i've got a production meeting for this
pilot that i'm producing and i've got a
production company so we've got a couple
shows in the works
and um you know i've got uh shows that
i'm on like i'm on american gigolo on on
uh showtime starting in january is when
i think we we start shooting i've got
deals a lot of [ __ ] all of this stuff
which it's beautiful but at the end of
the day i want all of that stuff to
to just that's my platform that i can
use all my work to give me the platform
to do the thing that i want to do which
is the academy so i can teach people so
so i can find a kid that's like wayne
and go hey let me help you out because
nobody was there to help me out do you
believe in uh do you believe in
burnouts have you ever felt burned out
from uh
from from from life or just kind of from
acting like as a competitor he's box
he's absolutely i'm a mixed martial
artist as well and there comes a point
like your love is like god leave me
really
well you can feel burn out and i feel
that i felt burned out because i did
things wrong at a certain point you
don't have to say yes to everything
and
time is a finite thing it's this little
pamphlet if the power of no
the power yes
i've read that
that's when i got hip to it it's
beautiful listen listen no one's so
awesome i'm gonna do it anyway i'm gonna
move i'll give you the money they want
but yes they hear the word no first and
see how they respond being able to say
no is a powerful thing because you can't
keep giving away your time
you can't keep giving away your time
talk to us a little bit about uh about
excel
oh oh my daughter's single
yeah yeah man man if you guys watching
look up uh google miley brady m-a-i-l no
we don't have to because we're gonna
play it right now we want to see it we
want to see you that's mine
everything in the world so the fact that
i've got a daughter studying a drama at
loyola and she's studying drama music
and social justice
so her whole aim is to use her athletic
powers
18. so she's in this generation right
now they're trying to use their art to
get out ahead and she's just right here
yeah she's just playing
she and she's
she's just
like ev everything that i am is wrapped
up in that one package wow
[Music]
and my ex-wife directed the music video
and her her boyfriend shot it and i
helped to produce it and to produce the
music so we do everything as a family
now we are family even though we're not
together we all family yes sir because
of that oh damn that's so cool man
that's so cool to see my
my brother just had a national
tournament and a couple of boys just won
nationals and i can only see like the
father how proud they are how proud you
are of your daughter bro watching her
take the same footsteps as that and well
the ego part of me to quote mike is very
proud because i'm like oh she's she's
falling in my footsteps and i help make
her when that is done
me me me i did that but
in reality
i'm proud of this human being regardless
of whatever she decided to do
and you know we still don't know if
she's just going to be a performer she
wants to go to law school at some point
she wants to do these other things
right so whatever she does i'm proud of
her because i'm proud of this human who
now exists outside of me she's making
her own choices and
at least i know that if the lord took me
tomorrow i've done one good thing on
this planet and it's to help make make
her
wow
that's
beautiful yeah so that's
that makes me very happy that makes me
very happy to see that she's out there
in the world and
and uh that's why i wanted to start the
academy as well i loved being a father
so much and i didn't grow up with my
father which is a part of the
generational trauma that you experience
in in some black households and
in a way
i'd like to
be that figure for a lot of young men
that don't have that yeah to be able to
to supply mentors and supply a way of
being with
with with my art saying i i'd like to
help your your journey through my art
what's the greatest advice anybody has
ever given you wayne yeah the greatest
advice anyone's ever given me is to and
i didn't know how to do this when it was
given to me years ago by
by um by my manager at the time this
dude named bernie brillstein who was one
of show biz greats like one of the last
old school guys he said
all those guys he used to manage all
those cats he managed you know he knew
sammy and he's responsible for snl and
for all of these cats his um his piece
of advice to me when i first got on was
you have to learn who you are
and be true to you and that sounds so
cliche and it sounds so easy but the
reality is especially in a business of
show when we're all performing to a
certain degree and you're asked to be so
many people to so many people
when you don't know who you are you lose
yourself in the shuffle and i didn't
really learn i'm still on that journey
and i'm 49 i'm just really in the past
few years i'm just peeling back the
layers to go oh this is who i am this is
the [ __ ] that i won't take these are the
walls that i will build and these are
the things that i will do i'm just
learning that so to someone new and
young in this business or just in life
start the process early learn to be who
you are and don't take your own
intrinsic value from all these other
cats well this is what uh from what you
just said man um
you gotta just know who you are but um
from my father-in-law perspective right
this moment uh right this moment
if we know who we are whole totally then
we have a limited um
thinking of ourselves you know we're
still learning yeah we're still we're
not going to be this person for long no
yeah because you'll be different
tomorrow yeah this is just who we are
for the moment this is not who we are
you know sometimes we are certain ways
just for survival or for happiness
in fact over the course of your lifetime
and and this is one of those facts when
i found out i was like oh that makes
sense
you know that your cells replace it you
you know they die and and they get
replaced
at a certain point in your lifetime you
are on a cellular level a completely
different person
so if you can wrap your mind around that
that if your cells which inform so much
of what you do and who you are and your
your cells have
memory
you can change you can be a different
person you can grow
and some of us feel locked in
that's not the truth you you have to set
up opportunity for others that's why i
want to do do the school and that's what
i'm trying to set up
everything don't let you tend to think
that that's what you saw how long sammy
and franken these guys those guys were
dedicated to dying on the stage
yeah yeah yeah go ahead go ahead and
look into one of the cameras you want to
tell mike i just think that he's a
beautiful brother i think
i always say he's the coolest he's the
most conscious straight brother you know
every time you play straight yeah going
by all the rules and stuff people call
you uncle tom and all that stuff yeah
but he's so conscious yeah you know i
mean when i first met him i was one of
those people and then when i first met
him and saw his depth i said wow he's
one of us and that's truly the art of
life
to make somebody believe that you're
something that you're not
yeah i mean i appreciate you man and and
and likewise you know i tell tell that
story of of when i saw the depth of mike
tyson the man
and the journey that you've been on
that the lives you've led
and the things that you've been willing
to learn
and to let go of and the healing that
you've done
that's inspiring that's inspiring
because the narrative could have just
gone one way with folks going oh yeah
well i know my tyson story mike da da da
da
you took that narrative you owned up to
that narrative you change that narrative
and you're still working and i'm kind of
like you know
mike started from this deaf deficit and
look who he is now and continues to work
on that and that's inspiring to me well
you know i don't know if i have any
power i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
anyway it's from being kind and
compassionate yes that's my power if i
have any yes that's your power but
that's the thing is not everyone
attributed that power to you because
they had one thought
and that's the thing that you even just
by doing this show and doing the things
that you do out in the world a movie or
you know the cartoon or you can make fun
of yourself in the video you were
showing uh other cats who may have the
mindset of well i'm you know i'm hard
i'm going to do something like my no but
i know like the hardest dude
is the dude who was willing to be open
and that's you you know can i tell you
something about me
after i met this most um german customer
everything is about i'm going to succeed
everything's about
competition
i don't know pride ego
jealousy
those are the um
those are the worst [ __ ] flaws they
have but this is my flaw to success
that's that's part of the thing whether
you're an athlete or or an entertainer
or there was a lawyer there are some
jobs where our faults are our fuel but
the challenge for us
is to never let
that fuel
overwhelm us and that's what happens is
is ego is cool but when your ego does
all your talking for you that's when you
get kicked in the ass at some point i've
been in that couple of hours yeah amen
and i've got a couple of boot prints
right now
you know it started at home before you
got a yes thought that home game kicked
an ad man thank you thanks for having me
mike thank you
you guys just watch the episode of hot
boxing with mike tyson i am your co-host
oh you got a bunch of
triple c and i'm mike tyson i love
having this show we have wayne brady
brady all these hundreds of millions of
people say something with the champ i
got to spend the day with the champ you
all be good to each other thank you
we out
[Music]
you